well we love you guys and we are so
happy that you're back you're going back
in studio i know the two of you are in
two different dressing rooms right now
but tell me when you get on set today
are there going to be tears of joy
i think so i mean we've already had a
really good rehearsal
but nothing beats live and because we're
all such
good friends um i think you're gonna
feel the love that we have for each
other coming through that camera
yeah it's so real absolutely what are
some of the major changes we're gonna
see
due to the pandemic uh what will viewers
see when they tune into the talk today
carry in we've definitely we definitely
have like a reconfigured set which is
super cool eve is coming in from london
and we have figured out a really cool
way of doing it that i can't wait for
our viewers to see
for us to connect and then we also have
a lot of new um
new segments which is really fun we're
going to start and show off with a daily
ketchup which is really cool
cheryl i like daily ketchup because i
like to dig in their business cheryl and
ask what did you do
what did you do last night i i think
that's great
and then carrie anne you like um which
one do you like having to talk about
you like oh you like feel good friday
okay so feel let me tell you what feel
good friday is because
this is great listen people are
struggling out there and we want to give
back we
understand the struggle so every other
friday the talk is giving away a
thousand dollars
to a small business or a hometown hero
because we want to
inspire people and we also want to help
people uplift their spirit so people
that are struggling
we're going to help them out financially
and also we'll talk about their business
and hopefully give them exposure
and share really feel good stories of
hometown heroes
amazing i like to talk talks back
because it's our it's a social media
connection
so we're going to have a social media
because you know the young people they
like social media did you know that um
i'm a tic toc sensation did you know
that
searle carrier none of your questions
i did not know 900 000 people are
lip-syncing to a joke that i
told i did not know that i i did not
care about so oh it's a track pants on
i can't let you see that are you doing
this cheryl no no
no no they're lip-syncing to me so
they're doing a joke but what i love
about the talk talks back is that
we will be communicating with our
audience through social media
and you know if you want to talk to us
if you want to give us topics to talk
about or you just want to weigh in in
some way we'll be doing that as well
uh i like eat up too i think eat up is
going to be really really good
this is oh yeah we're going to do some
cooking
i love that you guys uh you definitely
entertain but you also
educate and you offer a platform for
people to be themselves and i think
that's a big part of
what draws us all to all of you you're
so incredible
um and you're dancing on the couch
carrie anne i love that that was very
good
there's no judging no judging from me
i'm the judge we don't get to judge me
is we have a new theme for the show and
the new theme is speak up and be
heard and that's what we want for our
viewers to feel because people are
isolated we want them to be able to
speak up
through social media and connect with us
and we on the panel
we've been going through our own
isolation as well so now we also get to
speak up
about the same issues that everyone at
home is going through we'll be
sure we'll be talking about things that
everybody else was talking about
exactly we'll be doing a tribute to uh
one of my opinion one the most impactful
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
listen this is the year the woman we
already know it you know
so we're going to weigh in on things
like that we're going to talk about
everything that's going on in
entertainment
you know you never know what we're going
to say one thing i love about the talk
the chemistry is there on the show
between
us we talk about things that everybody
else wants to talk about
we weigh in we laugh we joke we cry we
empower we entertain
and we educate at the same time and i
think you're going to love it
absolutely sure i know that
[Laughter]
yes yes okay yes and we'll still be
doing you know
we'll be doing beauty tips like we
always do we'll have integrations
now you know we want people to know what
great products are and today we got drew
barrymore
and i can't wait to ask her about
something personal that she and i
have in common and um we gotta who is uh
sterling k brown did you sterling k
brown we've got jenny mccarthy wahlberg
we've got roblo we've got dr phil aisha
curry's going to be here
we've got i want to ask about her body
sarah her body is banging
amazing amazing bodybuilding's right
there
yes body goals so tell me though i have
a question there's so many different
changes and and yet the the things that
we love remain
the same but marie osmond has has is not
on the show anymore
are you going to be rotating a guest
host or what can you tell us about that
situation
well what i can tell you is uh watch the
show today
we will be talking about uh how we feel
about
our love for marie and and uh what will
be the next steps
and i think to address things like that
you know with the four of us i think
people will you know because you need a
certain level of consistency
in these times we do hope you need a
certain level of consistency
and we will be responding to uh
what that situation will be and what
what it is you know what i'm saying
we're going to keep it real with the
people that's what we do at the talk we
don't sugarcoat
nothing we got love for each other you
know we don't we don't do things that a
lot of people
you know uh need to be doing you know
we're going to show appreciation you
know what i'm saying yeah
you know we just love her maybe you lead
a little canadian popping in from time
to time
real talk okay two shirts
they gonna be so jealous that there's
two cirls on the show
see i'll be like cheryl cheryl yeah
that's right every
time they ask you a question i'll answer
that'll be a matter of it
that's perfect and you got to bring this
in that poutine bring me some poutine
definitely i'm going to ship it right up
there you got this yes you got it
you guys are actually powerful inspiring
women
and you know everyone on the show is you
know before the pandemic we all had this
hustle and this go
go go go go um i know what i've learned
about me my family and the way i was
doing business before but what did you
guys
discover about yourselves during this
time that maybe you want to hold on to
uh when we do get back to normal okay
great question well i mean really truly
i think this time the pandemic has given
us a lot of gifts even though it's taken
many people's lives it's also
for those who are here it's learning to
adapt it's also learning i think the
pandemic and the isolation has taught us
that we were taking a lot of things for
granted
and we were living a life of excess and
things that
we were doing things that we didn't need
to be doing and wasting time and money
on things that weren't important and i
think everybody's lives got smaller and
we got much more connected to
what was important which is family
friends your health
your mental health how you eat how you
spend your money i think it was so
powerful i have learned so much about
myself then that's making me even more
excited to get back
out there so that we can all share all
the things that we learn because
that's part of what the talk is all
about is sharing what we what we've
learned and what we've been through i
mean
i have lupus and the pandemic was hard
on my body and i know that people with
illnesses
really struggled because the added
pressure created so much more stress
internally and physically it manifested
so i struggled
but i had these ladies and we connected
you know we were doing the talk at home
but that connection
got me through it and we want to
continue to offer that to people and
each other
yes and for me i think what i've what
i've learned is
um the essential worker is so necessary
and need to be protected the first
responders the people that are
stocking the grocery stores is the
quality of life
issues that we who hold a microphone and
stand in front of a camera
we need to illuminate the necessity to
protect
people you know and we have to be
out there and be spokesperson to say
listen it is time for you to be heard
that's why i speak up and be heard that
that's our season 11
mantra and we want people to understand
you all are part of this
we are all in this together and if we
work together
we can make things even better it
shouldn't be
a have and i have not it should be there
is enough for everyone to have
that's it